I you know when it's part of the writing
game you put it you put your book out
you write a screenplay and movies made
you're gonna be subject to criticism you
know in the old days there was a few
reviewers and professional critics now
everybody who owns a computer whether
they own a brain or not can weigh in
with their opinions and you know you get
to read all these things on Amazon or
whatever and sometimes they make good
points Sunday I mean I read sometimes
reviews to point out something in my
books where I made a mistake or maybe I
should have thought about something and
I okay I'll think about that more but
there's also criticisms that just annoy
the [ __ ] out of you because they you
reject them and and for me one of the
ones that I hate most is this word
gratuitous I'm constantly being accused
of gratuitous sex gratuitous violence
gratuitous feast scenes right through
this heraldry you know and if you take
out everything that these idiots
consider gratuitous you would have the
Cliff's Notes version which is basically
a plot summary you know and and then
they fought a battle and this side one
okay that's what happens in terms of
advancing the plot but advancing the
plot is not what it's all about it's
about immersing you in the world and you
know violence and sex and feces and said
all that you're never gratuitous they're
part about making it real making
immersing you in feeling you in this and
the details are important space free
sexes is offensive on the on the face of
it because every sex act is different
according to the partners who are in it
and you know it also affects the
relationships of the characters
afterwards some sex is not so good you
know it is something sometimes you laugh
and break up and sometimes somebody
can't get it up and sometimes you
dissolve it into a fight in the middle
of it then sometimes somebody wants to
be punched that who the [ __ ] knows but
it illuminates the character and it
determines the arc of the characters
after that sex scene and you should give
the details and battle scenes violence
I've written stories that are you know
in which no one dies and which there is
no violence that's
that's perfectly legitimate you want to
write a story like that good but if
you're gonna write a story about war and
it's gonna have battles and sword fights
of people and axes and it don't just
make it clean there's something
offensive about clean violence like the
movies I watched in the 50s and TV shows
you know Gunsmoke Matt Dillon drawers is
gun and shoots the bad guy falls down
you know no how about the head
splattering and the Bloods and brains
going everywhere that's what it's really
like you know if you're gonna talk about
guns and axes and swords show what
they're really like that's your
obligation I think as an author if you
don't want to include violence don't
include violence don't have fight scenes
don't write about war but if you're
gonna write about that stuff do it
honestly and that means showing it in
all its horror and ugliness and visceral
stuff people with their entrails hanging
out screaming in pain and begging for
their mother that's what medieval
battles were all about yeah and don't
think that by escaping the war senior
escape the gore because if you're gonna
rant about okay we're not gonna have the
bath of it it's gonna have afterwards I
have news for you oh what a battlefield
looks like you know or what what do
people look like when they're coming
home if I was I was looking at some
World War one photos of soldiers coming
home and we have this romanticized view
some of those guys are coming home with
half a face and these are the ones
living and you know moving in the world
my response of people talk about
gratuitous exes but if you're not having
gratuitous sex what are you having gab
sex you also both of you have an
interesting an interesting detachment
from characters that you you seem to
have no compunction about killing them
all for George when one when one might
be tempted to hold on to a character
that your audience is endeared to
you don't seem to have that impulse and
further yet there's also I read a little
relish in it when when when they depart
the narrative and I'm wondering how is
it for you as writers when that moment
comes when a character must go
does that evolve in the telling of the
story or do you have a relationship with
your characters in a way where you you
just know that this person can't last
well I think it depends on the character
in the situation I mean you know from
very early stage in writing Song of Ice
and Fire I knew that certain characters
were going to have to die and and I knew
more or less when when they when they
died yeah Ned was was I mean that's a
fairly classic template it's not like I
invented that it's uh in some ways it's
Frank Herbert's doing you know you you
get rid of the father because the story
is really about the children and I just
extended a little further and made Ned
seem more important and brought him more
to life then then Frank Herbert did with
Leto Atreides and therefore his death
had more impact one of the things that I
hate in in you know we again we write
the books we want to read and what kind
of books I do I not want to read why do
not want to read books that are utterly
predictable and I get a lot of them you
know I get a book sent to me and I read
the first chapter or something and I
know exactly how it's gonna go
here's the hero his new villain the
hero's gonna get in a lot of trouble at
the end but ultimately he's gonna be
triumphant and here's the here's the
girlfriend he's gonna get her at the end
and etc you can see this story just laid
out I don't want my stories never be
predictable that I want to surprise the
reader and and affect the reader
emotionally and you know this question
of death is death is a big thing
in real life death affects us I'm sure
everybody in this auditorium has had
someone die apparent at both parents a
sibling some god help you a child which
is probably the hardest thing and all a
best friend I've lost three friends in
the last year and there every one of the
death had an impact on me and was
gut-wrenching
but infection too often death is is just
thrown in as an act break doesn't have
any emotional resonance you know I mean
people say I kill so many people
star wars you know a blew up the entire
planet of alderaan and you know before
the credits practically oh all they're
on is gone the billion voices have
ceased do you give a [ __ ] about any of
them no [ __ ] okay
they were Alderaan is gone but I don't
want to do that kind of death I want to
I want to affect you with a death of a
fictional character the same way you'd
feel if if a friend or a loved one died
I want you to feel that death I want my
books to engage you and emotionally I
want you to laugh at the funny parts and
get hungry when I describe a feast and
get horny when I read a sex scene or
either that or be repelled if it's ugly
sexually and but engage you emotions I
mean that to my mind emotion emotional
involvement is what friction is all
about if you want to make an
intellectual argument essay is a
wonderful form non-fiction journalism
there are great things to make an
intellectual argument but fiction is
about engaging the emotions yeah it's to
my other topic sex and violence you know
of other advance to be violent you know
and sex should be sexy and and death
should have the impact of death it's
it's and there are quite a few copy
things I thought of one being for a lot
of fantasy including my own a lot of the
template is medieval times in the
medieval times there are tons of death
it's if your family has three children
it means nine died it is
few minutes of 50 god bless you because
you're not gonna make it to 52 so it's
it's a it is such a constant presence in
medieval life what am i development I
mean up to 1950 chances are your
grandmother isn't telling you that yes
you have you have a grandmother grand
uncle but six of us died before in 1942
so it's so it's something that is so
ever-present but I think it's one of
these things with feelings a contract
and and I'm not knocking film what film
is like play a large role in in this
unwritten contract we seem to have that
nobody should die Tom Cruise is in the
film so clearly is gonna make it to the
end I think you should or not you know
it's it's it's worried since we're
absence in the cycle the second theme
bout you man I remember when psycho Kimo
psycho horrified viewers cuz I hold on
you're killing the main character in the
middle of the show what what what do we
do now but huge influence using effect
yeah yeah and particularly psycho
because in some times the death doesn't
always happen like that but it does and
I think that that that it should
resonate I remember one of the questions
when the questions are criticism I tend
to get a lot is that my stories are
drenched in violence or valence heavy
and Alison no they're not I said there's
a difference between preponderance and
resonance Matt they're far more mundane
it you know far more men and women died
in every action flick than in my story I
mean at the end of a Schwarzenegger
movie chances are 70 people were killed
if not if not more or or Alderaan blew
up so 50 million people were killed but
it's is none of but if but if one scene
of death one scene of violence that has
suffering for example that's the thing
there's lots of valleys where there's no
suffering there's lots of death but
there's no grief is even a ways in which
you write sex like you know sex and
there's a lot where they call space
Break sex please define the space break
sex would be and he said come
to me now space break the next morning
was like but there's certain things that
happen there and and the idea that that
sex itself is something that's loaded
with emotional resonance is ridiculous
there were nights in my 20s that I think
that there was space Brahe sex yeah yeah
but I think these these are essential
parts of human experience but they're
also very raw and disturbing and we we
take time to process them and but I
think that's but what better place to do
that in a book because you can sit with
a story you can sit with a chapter I'm
now sitting with a scene where where
Rochester is threatening Jane Austen
Jane Austen Jane Eyre with van and she's
good I couldn't have loved him more I'm
not girl says but but that's another
thing is supposed to use it what's the
lose sleep over a book it's supposed to
get you you know sweat a little bit
you should fret over characters and
their decisions particular when you know
they're about to make a bad decision and
and you know because again this is life
and it should also flow that way